direction versailles à présent un
phénomène inquiète autorités et
habitants depuis plusieurs semaines on
en parle avec vous et l'honneur si nokia
bonsoir ça la rédaction de tv 78 ce sont
des soirées appelé projet x qui sont au
coeur de la discorde
c'est en effet sur la place du marché à
versailles grigori que depuis deux
semaines des jeunes se réunissent en
nombre le soir plusieurs centaines tout
de même comme vous l'avez dit ce sont
des soirées projet x donc c'est en
référence au nom du film américain qui
sont organisés et planifiés via les
réseaux sociaux les week-ends le
problème c'est soirée dégénère et se
transforme en affrontement entre bandes
comme on peut le voir sur ces images de
nos confrères de bfm paris le week end
dernier le 4 juillet au soir des jeunes
ont même été blessées et deux
arrestations ont eu lieu tout comme le
week-end d'avant où une dizaine de
personnes avaient été interpellées
avec la violence cela pose aussi un
problème aux riverains et aux
commerçants de cette place qui dénonce
ce phénomène récurrent qui fait fuir
leurs clients certains riverains disent
même se sentir obligés de contourner la
place du marché pour rentrer chez eux
suite à cela le commissariat de la
police nationale de versailles a lancé
un appel à la responsabilité sur twitter
en demandant d'éviter les rassemblements
son respect des gestes-barrières ou
encore de ne pas se mettre en danger
suite à plusieurs vols et rixes à ce
propos julien le cam secrétaire régional
du syndicat alliance police nationale 78
a réagi au micro de tv 78 sur ce nouveau
phénomène
il faut savoir que ce genre de soirée la
plupart des personnes qui viennent sont
des jeunes qui viennent d'ailleurs qui
sont dans un esprit plutôt festif mais
simplement on s'est très vite des
groupes hostiles se joignent aux fêtards
et c'est là que les que les événements
dérape
la réaction c'est que malheureusement
cet événement qui était qui était prévu
à la dernière minute sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est fini dans dans la violence
par ça s'est fini par deux des
agressions c'est fini par des vols de
téléphones portables et forcément c'est
un peu l'incompréhension si parmi les
les forces de police ou jeunes fêtards
de faire très attention
1 faire très attention notamment
par rapport à leur téléphone par rapport
à eux mêmes restent en entre amis et que
s'ils voient justement des groupes
hostiles
on va dire arriver se joindre à la fête
de quitter mais mieux le plus vite
éviter justement de rester sur cette
place qui justement va attirer des
troubles fêtes et des individus parfois
très violents pour le moment pas
d'information sur une nouvelle une
troisième soirée projet x qui serait
prévue à versailles grégory et pas de
consignes particulières non plus en ce
qui concerne les forces de l'ordre mais
rien n'est moins sûr à mon avis que la
police nationale sera en alerte ce week
end
merci lots non pour cet éclairage